[Music]  i am so proud of you  do you know what a birthright is peter  [Music]  something that's a part of you like your  name  gardeners of the galaxy what no rocket  so i let groot fill out the paperwork  so we got fine we appear to be 6 963  units short  i know we clearly need a plan  if you see anything with gloves by the  tracks let me know  we got this  [Music]  drax roll nope  you want monster i'll show you monster  no  we disrobe keep your pants on although  it could be used as a distraction  we're all professionals here right maybe  we can work something out  you had one job quill i did exactly what  the more no killing teammates that's who  it's literally in your contract  i made no such commitment  in less than three cycles all would be  lost the galaxy  cannot be saved either quickly we  one more right  no no of course i will i'll call you  i'll call you  [Applause]  oh